frédéric veut vendre son appareil photo
il laisse cris sur un site internet de
petites annonces
il en demande 500 dollars à peine at il
terminé l'inscription son annonce qu'il
reçoit déjà un courriel un américain
s'intéresse à son appareil photo il est
même prêt à lui envoyer un chèque de 500
$ sur le champ du jour plus tard deux
chèques de l'américain henry
mais surprise il n'est pas de 500
dollars comme prévu
ou plutôt de 900 dollars frédéric écrit
un acheteur celui ci lui répond encaisse
le chèque et fais moi un virement de 400
$ pour compenser la différence
frédéric s'exécute et envoie et les 400
dollars et l'appareil photo
mais quelques semaines plus tard le ciel
tombe sur la tête sa banque lui apprend
que le chèque de 900 dollars qu'il a
reçus est sans provision
frédéric s'est fait plumer et des 400 $
qui navire et son appareil photo
cette fraude est bien connu elle a même
nom larnack du paiement entre ou le fin
mot de l'histoire
on trouve de tout sur le web eux mêmes
des voleurs soyez prudents